My career at NASA has kind of spanned a couple of decades at this point.
I arrived with the class of 2000, went through the training program...
...primarily focused on the space shuttle and the International Space Station,...
...learning those systems,...
...having launched a couple times on vehicles.
There's a lot of work and a lot of time that takes away from family...
...that my spouse appreciates, and I love her for that.
On a deeply personal level, I am really excited that my son is going to get a chance...
...to see me launch into space.
Being an astronaut has been a little bit of an abstraction thing for him...
...because he's seen me do it in old videos,...
...but he hasn't seen me do it for real...
...and so I'm so excited for him to see this launch.
Through years of the NASA team, I'm helping to share that experience...
...and teaching them the lessons that we've learned by going through this.
Now, there's another capability in the US besides NASA...
...to operate something of this magnitude.